hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round four of this
year's European Club cup we have Magnus
Carlson versus Alexis Arana Magnus
representing his Club off spill and
sarana representing sentimento AA bsk
and the reason I didn't cover it
yesterday I thought the game was a draw
as all of the websites showed that on
move 37 in what could only be described
as an equal position the players agreed
to a draw and I didn't put much thought
into it but later I found out that that
was not really where the game ended for
some reason I have no idea why ever
since chess.com bought everything
everything just stopped working like
it's a very very hard to actually find a
a working PGN you know uh most of the
times leeches has it perfect cover but
now leeches had it wrong chess 24 had it
wrong other IND you know separate
websites had it wrong and someone wrote
in the comments that there is a full PGN
on chess.com so that's where I pulled it
from uh so that's why I didn't show it
yesterday because it's a very very
strong game so let's check check it out
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with E4 and so far Magnus is on 100% in
his games he won all the games that he
played uh and of course having the white
pieces this is his strongest opponent so
far in the event uh but um well he does
have the white pieces and he chooses a
very very exciting opening so C5 Knight
F3 D6 and now going for Bishop to C4
this is actually the fifth most popular
continuation and one that really
shouldn't give any advantage to White
whatsoever but that's pretty much what
Magnus is going for in this event he
just wants to play chess uh you know
unequal terms from move one and throw
his opponent of course out of um you
know protective Waters of opening Theory
as soon as possible so Knight F6 Knight
to C3 uh E6 and now he strikes sorry in
the center with Pawn to D4 uh we have
captures and now Queen captures and D4
Knight captures is a a bit more popular
but Knight captures on D4 only a handful
of games and one of the players that
actually played Queen captures on D4 is
in in this position is Yan pan Forest
who is one of um well magnus's seconds
in the part of magnus's camp where he
trains so maybe that has something to do
with it but okay Knight to C6 attacks
the queen queen D3 and now Pawn to A6
with Bishop to F4 putting pressure on
that D6 Pawn so hoping to Castle here
and alexe plays a very very cool move
and that is Knight to G4 now there the
position has been reach before B5 has
been played here Bishop D7 has been
played even Knight H5 going after the
bishop uh but Knight to G4 uh has never
been played and it is now as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
so the idea is that uh okay you can't
Castle Queens side because uh Alexa will
just capture the pawn on F2 so Magnus
has to figure out what to do with the
King and he starts by going Rook to D1
uh so just putting more pressure on that
D6 pawn and Alexa oh goes Queen to B6
now attacking the B2 Pawn but the real
threat of course being Queen captures an
F2 Checkmate so Magnus stops this by
playing Queen to D2 and now we have
Bishop to E7 just continuing development
if you're wondering about the the juicy
B2 Pawn well we we could show what
happens the uh you you sort of trap the
queen with Bishop to B3 and uh then
after the queen tries to escape you go
Pawn to H3 you kick away the Knight
Knight F6 and now E5 and already black
has some problems here for example if D
captures Knight captures you cannot
capture with the Knight due to Checkmate
on d8 and you're going to have to play
Bishop D7 to cover that prepare the
castle now Knight C4 attacks the queen
and Knight the D6 check next will uh
prevent black from ever castling and the
white will have an excellent game so
that's why you don't capture on B2 here
so Bishop to E7 and now comes Bishop to
B3 we have Knight G to E5 uh also a very
standard idea in pretty much all the all
the Sicilian games you want to get your
knight to the E5 and then if white
captures you can choose between uh
capturing with a piece or playing d d
captures on E5 as even if you double
your pawns you will have a very nice
control of all the central squares here
so Pawn to H4 by Magnus trying to
discourage Alexi from castling King side
we have Queen to C7 adding additional
support to the D6 pawn and also
preparing to push on the queen side uh
Bishop to G5 and now Pawn to B5 we have
Bishop captures on E7 uh idea being that
now you can't really capture with the
queen uh this would allow Magnus to
capture on D6 so King captures his
played and now Queen to G5 with check
King to f8 and now Rook to H3 going for
a kingside attack with Rook to G3 so H6
Alexi kicks the queen back Queen to D2
and now Bishop to
B7 and uh this is a sacrificing a pawn
for activity if Alexa wanted he could
just play King back to E7 and then we
would see something like Rook to G3 Rook
to G8 maybe the knights get traded off
but after d captures an E5 and queen E3
three uh okay you could play it The Rook
not very active here the King on E7 you
have a doubled Pawn here which we
already discuss that it's really not a
bad doubled Pawn as you control a lot of
space here so it's a matter of um
personal preference but here Bishop to
B7 was played Alexis sacrifices a pawn
for activity and now it's time uh for
for Magnus to prove if it's uh if it's
doable now you could play Queen captur
and D6 first or you could play Knight
captures on E5 first so Magnus plays
Knight captures on E5 first sort of
allowing D captures on E5 which would
save Alexi the pawn but then you allow
Queen D7 it's a really a too active move
to allow for example Queen captures Rook
captures you have to guard the bishop
and it's just a really bad position Rook
F3 goes after the pawn here uh like F6
okay you can defend Rook G3 goes after
the other Pawn so it's not uh not not
the best so that's why after Knight
captures on E5 Alexa has to trade here
Knight captures Queen captures on D6 uh
Queen captures and The Rook captures so
now Magnus is up a pawn and King to E7
attacks The Rook we have Rook back to D1
and now Pawn to G5 now all of his pieces
are active Pawn to A3 stopping Pawn to
B4 and Bishop to C6 now preparing to um
push on the queen side as you need your
B5 Pawn defended uh Bishop to A2 and now
Pawn to A5 we have H captures on G5 H
captures and Magnus trades on h8 Rook
captures Rook captures and now uh of
course Pawn to B4 this is the absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
as it often is uh so a captures on B4 a
captures and Rook to H4 now putting
pressure on that E4 pawn and Magnus
defends it with Pawn to F3 so of course
Alexi goes um uh with a pawn push on G4
to undermine it and now Pawn to F4 we
have Knight to G6 attacking the F4 Pawn
now comes Pawn to G3 and Rook to H1
check King D2 Rook to H2 check King to
C1 and Rook H3 attacking the G3 Pawn now
Rook to D three we have Rook to H1 check
King to beat you and now Rook to E1
going behind the pawn Here and Now Pawn
to E5 so Magnus defends everything and
he still up upon and now if you look at
the position uh how is Alexia to
continue this game the bishop while a
very nice piece controlling this long
diagonal all of magnus's Pawns on the
king side are on dark squares even the
pawn on B4 is on a dark square and you
can't really do all that much with the
light Square Bishop so how do you attack
the G3 Pawn well you could attack it
with the Rook but you could attack it
with the Knight you have to move the
king play Knight to A7 Knight to F5 and
then really put pressure on that G3 pawn
and by you know asking yourself such a
question how do I approach this you find
your next move easily and that is King
to E8 bringing up the E6 E7 Square for
the Knight so okay Knight to D1 Magnus
counters this immediately now if uh
Knight to E7 is played now just Knight
to E3 guarding D F5 Square so nothing
really happening here so Bishop to E4
attacking the rook and Rook to D2 and
this is a basically where all of the
websites have shown that the game ended
in a draw and that no more moves were
played and when that in fact could not
be further from the truth and here uh
the move to play is not the move Sara
played he played Rook to G1 which is
very nice it's actually the second
strongest move recommended by the engine
but the top move is Knight captures on
F4 and now Magnus cannot capture back if
he captures back then G3 and what do you
play here the G2 square is covered by
the bishop the G1 Square covered by The
Rook so once G2 is played you're going
to have to give up your Rook for this
Pawn for example Knight C3 okay you
could attack the bishop but just Bishop
F3 with G2 next and you win the exchange
you're going to have a great game so
after Knight captures on F4 uh you're
going to have to play Knight to F2
attack the bishop and the pawn here and
once the Knight moves now now you're
going to capture on G4 and okay the game
continues Magnus still having a lot of
pressure on the position here uh but all
in all should be a draw however after
this uh Rook to G1 was played and now
comes Knight to C3 now Magnus is okay
you have your G3 Pawn I'm going to have
the B5 pawn and now again Bishop to C6
is the way to go Alexi goes for Bishop
to F3 he keeps the bishop and gets ready
to capture on G3 and start pushing the G
Pawn Knight captures on B5 and now Rook
captures on G3 so it's a you know it
looks like a very double-edged position
but the uh you know truth of the
position uh says completely otherwise
Magnus is completely winning here so
feel free to pause the video and find
the winning move while I give you a
couple of seconds and this is move 39 so
one more move had to be made to reach
time control uh so you know do do your
best so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on always
studying the end game and becoming a
true Master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to F5 this is such a
devastating move for black um that
doesn't matter how you meet it you you
will uh you will very quickly perish now
of course if e captures on F5 which is
kind of a you know the the obvious thing
to do Knight to D6 check and now if you
go here if you go here or if you go here
sorry that's a weird Arrow uh any of
these moves will be punished with Knight
captures um on F5 and it will either be
a fork on E7 or a discovery from The
Rook here and you just pick up the Rook
on G3 for free so the only move is King
to f8 and now again Knight captures on
F5 wins The Rook because if you save The
Rook then Rook to d8 is Checkmate the
Knight covers these two squares E7 and
G7 and Rook d8 will be Checkmate so
after F5 you cannot touch the F Pawn you
have to play Knight captures an E5 which
is the strongest move but it doesn't
help all that much because what does
Magnus play now and this was the really
hard move to find when you decided to
play F5 and that is Pawn to F6
absolutely incredible now again covering
E7 and G7 and now if you play something
like Rook to G2 let's say you offer a
rook trade Here Comes Knight to C7 check
King f8 and Rook to d8 Checkmate so you
don't have time for such a move you have
to play Knight to D7 only move that
keeps the game going for Alexi now
Knight to D6 check and now look at this
if you go King to d8 and King to d8 is
the absolute best move for black um that
sort of keeps black in the game then you
capture on F7 with check you have to go
to C7 and then after Knight to G5
preparing to advance this Pawn you will
play Knight captures now comes Knight
captures on E6 with check King to C6 and
Bishop to C4 cutting off the king from
the B5 square and now you start
advancing the pawn you're up a pawn and
you you you should win this game with
white but still black can give you a lot
of problems however after King to f8 the
game is now completely winning for
Magnus and I'm sure you guys know the
move be because it's the theme of the
position and that of course is Knight to
F5 uh this is what Magnus played and he
was in this position on move 43 that
Alexis Sara resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here why do
you resign here well The Rook is
undefended on G3 which means you either
give up The Rook uh or you take the
Knight or you move the Rook but doesn't
really matter for example you capture
the Knight Rook captures on D7 Checkmate
being threatened here so you have to
play this now Rook E7 check King to d8
and Rook captures on F7 and there's just
no stopping the F Pawn for example Rook
H3 you go Bishop to E6 now put pressure
on these pawns and if G3 you play Rook
to D7 check King E8 F7 with check King
f8 and now Rook to d8 with check the the
the pass Pawn on F7 is defended King G7
you can now play f8 Queen and very
quickly you get checkmated to King H7
Bishop captures on F5 will be Checkmate
and any other move doesn't really help
you so you either take or you lose the
Rook uh but uh you know doesn't really
matter like you could play Rook to G1
just move the Rook then Rook captures on
D7 you're down a piece still Checkmate
is being threatened there's just uh no
way out of this so uh yeah very very
very uh good game by both of them Sara
really uh held his own with the black
pieces here uh but after this idea of
not defending the pawn on B5 with Bishop
to C6 he went for Bishop to F3 and went
for this trade uh F5 the threat of F5 F6
completely destroyed him and it's a
position that you could have very often
against the cilian pawn E5 point to F4
and if you know these um uh well sort of
motives then you will be able to maybe
employ such a tactic in your own games
now you're not going to have the exact
same position but just knowing the idea
might you know uh sort of get you a
different idea that will help you win
the game or Draw or you know just solve
the position uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it Magnus
remaining on 100% three wins out of
three games very nicely done I would
like to thank ala uh uh dreo is the best
data uh Lake engine Kate Ingram Dennis
charbono and Mr hoody guy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching watching and
I will see you soon continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have a excellent rest of your day
and uh the uh simultaneous exhibition
against ala is starting soon you still
have a chance to play him uh first link
in the description below everything is
explained uh see you soon